the late american defense secretary
donald rumsfeld famously said that there
were three types of knowledge in war
known knowns
known unknowns and unknown unknowns that
is things that we know that we know
things that we don't know
and things that we don't even know
that we don't know
but there is a fourth type
of war knowledge
known unknowns that is things we think
we know that in fact we do not know
and when it comes to the war in ukraine
it is that fourth kind of knowledge that
we are all full of everyone knows for
instance about the ghost of kiev the ace
fighter pilot who shot down five maybe
even seven russian fighter jets on just
the first day of fighting we know about
him because we read about him on social
media we even saw videos of his heroics
in the sky
except we didn't
the video isn't real
the airplane isn't even real
it's a cartoon from a digital combat
video game
everyone knows for instance
that ukrainian president volodymir
zelensky is not only refusing to flee or
surrender but is actually fighting on
the front lines we know this because
we've all seen the photos of him wearing
combat fatigues gun in tote
except
the photo isn't from last week it's
actually from months ago and a long way
from kiev here we go reuters fact check
everyone knows
about the 13 brave sailors guarding
snake island who refused to back down to
a russian ship whose final words to the
russians were
go f yourself before all 13 were killed
we know this because we saw the video
this is the russian worship comes up
this is the russian warship i repeat
i suggest you surrender your weapons and
capitulate otherwise i will open fire
do you copy okay and then this is just
you're just seeing this on the island
you're hearing this audio ukrainian said
this is it
should i tell him to go f himself
just in case
turns up the volume
russian warship go f yourself
and then
we were told they were all killed but
what a way to go out we saw that happen
except we didn't
it turns out the sailors happily were
probably not killed but captured as even
the ukrainian foreign ministry now
admits
none of this is to take away from the
bravery of the ukrainians those sailors
there they seem like pretty tough dudes
okay regardless of whether they were
killed or captured
the ukrainian servicemen the civilians
and president zielinski himself are all
demonstrating immense bravery
but most of the stories you're hearing
right now about this war seem incredible
precisely because they are not credible
they are the product of dueling
propaganda machines with both sides
going into overdrive to spin the best
yarns to help their side
this war is unlike anything we've seen
in my lifetime it occurred to me a
couple of nights ago
that this is the first
major war in my lifetime to take place
between civilized nations
and it's all the more frightening
because our political elite in the west
did not believe it could actually happen
i'm so glad you liked that clip you know
by the way if you want to watch me
compete against the big boss himself ben
shapiro we've got a new episode of face
off
famous dead guys edition
listen i've gone up against dave rubin
i've gone up against matt walsh now i'm
going up against ben himself the results
i don't want to spoil anything the
results might surprise you go check out
that episode go subscribe to the michael
knowles show at apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]